the prime minister touched on this but
which local areas will be in
each tier this is the red hot question
this is the question everybody's going
to be asking
over their kitchen table tonight i had a
round table
with business leaders this morning and
it's the first question they
asked me the prime minister says it will
be decided later this week possibly
thursday i just can't emphasize how
important it is that these decisions are
taken
very quickly and very clearly so
everybody can
plan that's obviously particularly
important
for the millions who are in restrictions
before the national lockdown because the
message to them today seems to be
you will almost be certainly be back
where you were
before the national lockdown probably in
even stricter restrictions and people
need to know that
so they can plan for that and i really
emphasize how important that is
for the prime minister secondly
um and the prime minister said he wanted
uniform rules will the tiers simply be
imposed
region by region come what may from the
3rd of december
or will there be an element of local
consultation
and negotiation i understand the uniform
rules
but simply to impose it runs the risk of
not getting buy-in from local leaders
and local communities which is
incredibly important to people
uh complying with the rules
third how long does the prime minister
anticipate each local area will it will
remain in each tier for those that are
going to come out of lockdown and almost
certainly go back to more restrictions
than they left
that's going to be a very very pressing
question for them
and then fourth will there be a new
economic package to accompany these new
tiers there's huge concern among many
businesses about the viability in tier
three particularly a strengthened tier
three
so what new support can they uh expect
and can i touch again
on those who are self-employed who are
outside of the self-employed
scheme the so-called excluded because
they will be hearing a message about the
next three months
in relation to schemes they are not
currently in and that needs
urgently to be addressed